doctor how could this happen to my  favorite youtuber he hasn't posted in  over six months he used to post nearly  every day it's almost like youtube's  algorithm incentivizes and even  encourages creator burnout no it's  definitely not youtube's fault probably  just forgot to put hashtags in his  descriptions um okay we're doing  everything we can to cure his channel we  have him steadily posting youtube shorts  right now shorts but won't that only  mask the underlying problem okay maybe  shut the [ __ ] up maybe i'm the doctor  for a reason  okay so now all of his videos are going  to be premieres he has to go live three  times every day do you think he'd  consider opening every video mr beast  style  you know um  hey guys